modest dance I mean I think one thing
we've learned over the last eight years
the obvious one is you can't bring
democracy at the barrel of a gun I mean
I think people would have known that in
the first place even the bush people
don't say that they that's what they
sought to do though it sure looks like
that's what they saw to do the point is
what can you do what can any outside
actor including the United States do to
try to bring more democratic outcomes in
countries and I think there's I tend to
talk about it as a kind of high thing
and a low thing the low thing which
happens with nobody particularly
noticing it is the slow effort and
building up institutions the State
Building part of this and and this is a
key aspect but a very gradual a stick
one where you try to help countries with
issues of rule of law and transparency
and limiting corruption as well as
helping to build infrastructure and so
forth that's the low thing the high
thing the dramatic thing these are
public diplomatic acts so how can the
United States make a difference there
well there are some times when elections
are enormously consequential and it
really matters a lot for the United
States to come down on the right side we
saw recently in Pakistan of the United
States was on the wrong side and the
Democratic civilians secular parties
succeeded anyway so it shows the limits
of our power for bad as well as for good
but there are moments when it is
enormously important for the United
States to say there is a democratic side
and there is a not Democratic side or
less Democratic side and we stay
to take a which i think is not
dispensable you hear people say oh in
the Middle East we have a tradition of
Islamic democracy we call it the Shura
which is to say a council of elders who
together reach a consensual conclusion
well that's not a democracy that does
not represent the will of the people and
especially in a complex society as
opposed to a tribal society a sherratt
will not be a useful reflection of
people's will will and will not be
sufficiently accountable to them and
will not be counterbalanced by other
powers as well so there's an example
where I would say the local customs
don't get you there or the Loya Jirga in
Afghanistan there are very important
transitional devices but they are not
the thing itself at the same time there
are lots of elements of things like how
power is divided between the center and
the locality where the United States has
a particular way of doing it that's very
different from our western other Western
democracies much less than other African
countries there are systems of
adjudicating a more traditional systems
of the of justice for example which can
live alongside more Western systems of
justice so queerly there is not a
one-size-fits-all aspect to democracy
but it's a big mistake to think that
it's so variable that there are not a
series of quite fundamental practices
values institutions which are essential
for anyone
you